ok a next game I lost a couple of
seconds at the beginning yeah I was
slightly in nimes oh um yeah let's play
this f3 line which I am I'm recommended
in one of my my repertoire videos check
our c6 yeah this is an interesting
option I didn't don't think I am I
covered this in the videos it's really
um it's an interesting idea c6 bishop a
six black wants to play and he wants to
recapture with the seaborne if i take i
don't know what what is played on this
move I know that it's that that it
exists but I don't know what what's
white what why should play what about
really ought to aggressive way lucky for
us as possible it takes twice Queen g4
it doesn't look look too solid young
yeah but you three or something on chip
g5 oh come on no idea maybe this is just
completely ridiculous
the one he decided quickly on this yeah
of course but I thought I could I could
come up with 92 and then there's still
this issue here of course it doesn't
have my development yeah but it takes on
c3 I can play Bishop g2 and this night
is pin-to-pin to get lost well okay what
now the results just hanging Wow okay um
I've got an extra Brooke okay let's get
the Queen back so not very often that
you get an extra hook aunt is pretty
good player 2,500 rated here um okay
there is still um in this pin here
not quite sure how should I proceed
let's cover this first and then try to
complete development here
yeah I was somewhat slow
yeah I don't want to allow edge for
really but I could could just castle
actually f6 is some completely
overloaded yeah I need to close the
diagonal if you basically also plays
without his queen so now we should be
three just attacking the rook
yeah maybe soaping that um I just clock
for the sleep here something ok oh yeah
what everything wins that's what's the
quickest 1e classe resigns yeah made it
to 328 Kings is seven Bishop f4 yeah
well this was some yeah of course he
needs to to look here and try to avoid
material losses yeah while the computer
already gives me a lasted large
advantage here Queen f5 Queen g7 yeah
this is possible he's very weak on the
dark squares I think he just needs to
play Queen Knight to f6 now or done oh
don't take at all of course this is so
this is some somewhat somewhat risky
here maybe black should consider a move
like five or see five or something else
if Ivan or maybe not see fire but maybe
if 5v5 as an idea to get to get the
bishop out quickly also no idea maybe
this is playable after all before yeah
well quite quite funny games just
winning a look after 12 moose doesn't
happen too often okay let's start
another one